so und damit kommen wir zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt bleiben aber beim
Thema Bildung es geht um die 28
Novelle des Bundes
ausbildungsförderungsgesetzes das kennen
Sie wahrscheinlich unter Bafög gerade
erst im Sommer gab es ja eine
bafög-reform in mit der unter anderem
der Kreis der Anspruchsberechtigten
erweitert wurde und auch die Sätze
erhöht wurden aber die Bundesregierung
möchte jetzt noch mal etwas verbessern
ihrer Meinung nach denn während der
corona-pandemie haben viele Studierende
ihre Nebenjobs verloren weil es eben in
der Pandemie natürlich wirtschaftlich
auch schwierig war und da möchte jetzt
die Bundesregierung mit einer Art mit
einem Art notfallmechanismus eingreifen
können genaueres hören wir jetzt von Ria
Schröder bildungspolitische Sprecherin
der FDP-Fraktion
und wer das schon einmal gemacht hat der
weiß dass es im Gebirge zu plötzlichen
Wetter kommen kann
2020 haben die Studierenden in
Deutschland einen solchen
Wetterumschwung erlebt sie befanden sich
auf dem Weg zum Gipfelkreuz manche von
ihnen waren schon auf der letzten Etappe
andere haben gerade erst angefangen
freuten sich erwartungsvoll auf den
Aufstieg die corona-pandemie schlug ein
wie ein Blitz Deutschland ging in einen
monatelangen Lockdown Bars und Bühnen
waren leergefegt
hunderttausende Studierende verloren
ihren Nebenjob 50 Prozent weniger
Angebote für Jobs der Arbeitsmarkt für
Studierende brach ein und damit der
finanzielle Boden für ihren Aufstieg
die Jungen Liberalen haben damals
zusammen mit den anderen demokratischen
Jugendorganisationen der großen Parteien
gemeinsam die Öffnung des Bafögs für
diese Studierenden gefordert Kevin
Kühnert sitzt da drüben wir haben das
zusammengemacht freue mich dass du in
der Debatte dabei bist und übrigens auch
die Junge Union war mit dabei verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der cdu/csu
denn selbst den jungen Leuten in ihren
eigenen Reihen reichte nicht was ihre
Bundesbildungsministerin Karliczek
damals zusammen zimmerte die
Überbrückungshilfe
die Überbrückungshilfe die kamen zu spät
sie war schnell ausgeschöpft und sie
erinnern sich vielleicht auch nicht aber
die Studierenden die erinnern sich die
mussten nämlich mit Ihrem Kontoauszug
anrücken zu den studierendenwerken
mussten da zeigen das Konto ist
leergefickt und dann dann haben Sie mit
Glück ja 100 Euro bekommen wow also
echte premiumhilfe powered CDU die
konnten sich bedanken wir machen das
jetzt anders meine Damen und Herren
wir schaffen eine wir machen wir
schaffen eine dauerhafte rechtliche
Grundlage für Einbrüche des
studentischen Arbeitsmarkts das ist
fester Boden auf dem die Studierenden
sicher stehen können der Nothilfe
Mechanismus trägt der Realität der
Studienfinanzierung in Deutschland
Rechnung denn die meisten Studierenden
die finanzieren sich entweder über
Unterstützung durch ihre Eltern oder das
Bafög und daneben haben drei Viertel der
Studierenden einen Nebenjob und wenn der
aufgrund einer Notlage wegfällt dann
helfen wir in Zukunft mit unserer
Neuregelung diesen Studierenden schnell
flexibel und unbürokratisch
das bedeutet für uns konkret die
Digitalisierung des BAföG die wir erst
vor wenigen Wochen mit der 27 Novelle
vorangetrieben haben die setzen wir mit
der Integration des nothilfe-mechanismus
ins bafög-digital konsequent fort wir
sorgen damit für zukünftige Krisen der
Studienfinanzierung vor meine Damen und
Herren und ja auch jetzt auch jetzt
befinden wir uns in einer Krise genau
richtig wir befinden uns in einer Krise
aber die Situation ist eine andere wir
haben nämlich jetzt lieber Herr zombeck
wir haben jetzt eine Situation in der
nicht der studentische Arbeitsmarkt
bedroht ist sondern alle Menschen in
Deutschland alle Menschen in Deutschland
die echten unter Inflationen und
Energiekrise und deswegen Frau Staffler
deswegen braucht jetzt passgenaue
Lösungen das machen wir doch etwa zum
Beispiel auch für die regulär
geförderten bafög-empfängerinnen und
Empfänger die unterstützen wir mit dem
Heizkostenzuschuss ja das können Sie
ruhig mal anerkennen das können Sie
ruhig mal anerkennen und brauchen hier
gar nicht so rumzuschreien mit der
Erhöhung des Kindergeldes mit
unterstützen wir diejenigen die von den
Eltern unterstützt werden die Erhöhung
der minijob-grenze auf 520 Euro die
energiepauschale das hilft den
Studierenden jetzt ein Minijob haben
meine Damen und Herren das ist
zielgerichtet das kommt bei den
Studierenden an und das hilft Ihnen
durch den kalten Winter
liebe
Damen und Herren gilt es aber nicht
alles der Lockdown der hat auch zu
geschlossenen hörsäen zu verweisen
Mensen geführt das soziale Leben und
Lernen das ist im Studium genauso
wichtig wie die Vorlesung und das kam
fast völlig zum Erliegen und so wie man
eine Bergwanderung auch nicht alleine
machen sollte gilt das gleiche für die
Bildung und deswegen müssen in diesem
Winter die Hochschulen die Berufsschulen
die allgemeinbildenden Schulen offen
bleiben keine lockdown-spirale dafür
setzen wir uns ein
meine Damen und Herren auch wenn wir den
nothilfe-mechanismus heute beschließen
das werden wir ja tun ich werde
begeistert dafür zustimmen aber ich
hoffe für meinen Teil sehr dass wir
nicht in der Situation kommen dass wir
ihn brauchen denn ich hoffe dass die
Studierenden in Zukunft ohne Gewitter
den Aufstieg schaffen und vielleicht
noch einen Kommentar in Richtung Union
ich empfehle ihnen haben Sie doch mal
auf ihre Jugendorganisation wir machen
das bei den Liberalen so und stimmen Sie
dem Gesetz zu vielen Dank
Ria Schröder waren da ist die
bildungspolitische Sprecherin der
FDP-Fraktion hat hier die Novelle des
bafög-gesetzes verteidigt und jetzt
kommt der bildungspolitische Sprecher
der Union Thomas jaczombeck
liebe Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wenn es ein Beispiel gibt
für ein komplett nutzloses Gesetz dann
ist es das was hier vorliegt
ich werde sie noch erklären die Idee und
die Intention ist richtig die hatten wir
auch schon als wir hier noch in der
Regierung waren was haben sie aber
daraus was haben sie da draus gemacht
ich hören Sie mal eine Sekunde zu warum
ist das Gesetz nutzlos wir reden im
Ausschuss die ganze Zeit über Notlagen
in diesem Gesetz steht 36 mal Not aber
in dieser Notlage und der Krise die wir
offensichtlich haben wirkt das Gesetz
gar nicht sie brauchen dafür einen ganz
zweites Instrument diese 200 Euro Kiste
da komme ich gleich noch drauf dieses
Gesetz wirkt in dieser Notlage nicht es
bildet eine Notlage ab dies vor zwei
Jahren gab heute haben wir eine ganz
andere
dieses Gesetz und das ist der vielleicht
noch schlimmere Teil wird aber auch dann
nicht funktionieren wenn eine solche
Notlage Eintritt warum es gibt in
Deutschland 3 Millionen Studierende
davon sind zweieinhalb Millionen keine
Bafög-Empfänger wenn es tatsächlich dazu
kommt dass die sich nicht mehr
finanzieren können und hier Hilfe
brauchen dann werden zweieinhalb
Millionen Studierende eine E-Mail mit
einer individuellen Begründung ihrer
Notlage und wie es hier gefordert wird
mit Unterlagen beispielsweise Kündigung
ihres Jobs an ein Amt schicken dann
sagen Sie mir doch mal wer soll denn
händisch zweieinhalb Millionen Anträge
in irgendeiner akzeptablen Zeit
abarbeiten das ist völlig unmöglich
so und ich finde das ehrlich gesagt
wissen sie nach dem Vortrag der Kollegin
von der SPD die uns die Ganzheit erzählt
hat vorhin warum Digitalisierung in der
Bildung misst ist wundert mich da nicht
besonders viel aber dass die FDP dass
die FDP als die Partei Frau Ministerin
sie haben plakatiert digital first
Bedenken second sie haben ein
vollständig analogen Prozess für
zweieinhalb Millionen Anträge das doch
verrückt wir haben
wir haben wir haben einen
Änderungsantrag hier heute gestellt wir
haben ein Änderungsantrag gestellt dass
diese Anträge digital bearbeitet werden
müssen den haben sie im Ausschuss
abgelehnt ich kann nur sagen wenn sie
heute wieder gegen die digitale
antragsbearbeitungsstimmen dann gehen
sie bewusst bewusst in ein Gesetz von
dem Sie genau wissen es kann sein Nutzen
überhaupt nicht erfüllen
ist Kollege Gehring soll ich mal
erklären der Antrag ist digital ja der
antragsdigital das haben wir eingeführt
aber alles danach ist nicht mehr digital
und das ist das Problem an der ganzen
Sache zum zweiten Kollege Gehring ich
darf einmal auf sie kommen sie haben
lieber Kollege Gehring sie haben vor
ziemlich genau zwei Jahren haben sie
eine Definition einer trödelministerin
hier platziert
sehr gut weil nämlich drei Monate nach
Beginn der Krise keine Lösung da war
jetzt kann ich nur sagen am 18 Februar
hat dieser russische Einmarsch begonnen
bis heute ist für die Studierenden am
Ende nichts rausgekommen so und das Ding
ist das Ding ist sie haben jetzt
angekündigt weil sie merken dass diese
dass dieses Gesetz für diejenigen die
Hilfe brauchen nicht funktionieren haben
sie jetzt angekündigt dass alle
Studierenden 200 Euro bekommen sollen
wir haben gefragt wie sie das denn
eigentlich machen wollen wir haben
damals die corona-hilfen mit dem
deutschen Studentenwerk gemacht gehören
vom deutschen Studentenwerk das ist hier
nicht bereit sein wir haben von ihnen
bisher nicht erfahren wie Sie das machen
wollen und das spricht dafür das spricht
dafür dass wir hier in diesem Jahr gar
nichts mehr sehen werden wir werden Sie
an die trödelministerin am Ende erinnern
und eins darf ich Ihnen sagen wir haben
damals gerade mal sechs Wochen gebraucht
um diese corona-hilfen hinzubringen das
ist der Benchmark an dem müssen sich
messen lassen
so
und sie haben bei den 200 Euro auch noch
ein ziemlich großen Konstruktionsfehler
nämlich es sind ja nicht nur
vollzeitstudierende in diesem
Gesetzentwurf heute steht drin er gilt
nur für vollzeitstudierende bei den 200
Euro verhält es sich aber so dass
diejenigen und ich habe ein Stück im
Handelsblatt gefunden dass ein Student
der jeden Tag von Duisburg nach Köln
fährt der nur eingeschrieben ist für das
Studententicket der spart nach eigenen
Angaben in diesem Artikel 2800 Euro im
Jahr ist vollzeitbeschäftigt und dem
geben Sie jetzt noch 200 Euro on top das
kann ganz sicher nicht richtig sein und
und das ist ja kein Ausnahmefall sondern
ich lese mal weiter wie das Handelsblatt
ist schreibt da ist angeblich an der Uni
Düsseldorf die Zahl bei 8.000 solchen
Schein Studierenden an der Uni Köln
4.000 solcher Schein studieren und kreuz
und quer durch Deutschland das heißt sie
wollen 200 Euro an Menschen geben die am
Ende sie überhaupt gar nicht brauchen
weil sie keine Studenten sind und da
haben sie noch einiges zu tun werden sie
Ministerin der Chancen und nicht der
verpassten Chancen
wie kann Kindern und Jugendlichen am
besten geholfen werden in der Schule
wieder voranzukommen nach dieser für sie
besonders schwierigen Zeit darüber
sprechen die Abgeordneten und als
nächstes spricht darüber Lina Seidel
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen
Bildungsdebatten in diesem Haus laufen
zumindest seitdem ich Mitglied im
entsprechenden Fachausschuss bin
irgendwie immer gleich ab sie die Union
werfen unsere den Regierungsfraktionen
vor dass wir gar nichts Alternative zu
wenig alternativ alles falsch machen und
dass sie werden sie das
Bildungsministerium geführt haben den
Bafög zu neuem glanzverholfen haben wir
die regierungstragenden Koalition weisen
darauf hin dass in den letzten 16 Jahren
doch einiges liegengeblieben ist und
dass wir deshalb innerhalb weniger
Monate bereits zwei bafög-novellen durch
das Parlament gebracht haben und eine
dritte in den Startlöchern steht und es
geht dann immer so hin und her hin und
her irgendwann hat die Linke noch mal
ein paar Vorschläge hin her hin her der
Mehrwert für die Menschen außerhalb
dieses Saales da oben auf den Tribünen
in den Hochschulen in den
Bildungseinrichtungen im Land
vermutlich gering
und dabei sollten unsere Ziele doch
eigentlich die gleichen sein Weg von
einer rückwärtsgewandten Debatte wie wir
sie gerade auch wieder erlebt haben hin
zu mehr Lösungsorientierung einer
konstruktiven Fehlerkultur um jungen
Menschen eine möglichst sorgenfreie
Ausbildung zu ermöglichen
und das tun wir mit dieser 28
bafög-nelle in Zeiten in den quasi
stündlich eine neue Krise die
Schlagzeile bestimmen leisten wir Krisen
Vorsorge wir treffen damit die
notwendigen vorquerung wenn der
ausbildungsbegleitende Arbeitsmarkt
zusammenbricht und damit die Nebenjobs
von SchülerInnen und Studierenden
wegfallen dann öffnen wir das BAföG für
alle unabhängig von den gängigen
bafögkriterien wie Eltern Einkommen oder
dem eigenen Vermögen mit diesem Gesetz
geben wir jungen Menschen die Sicherheit
dass sie im Ernstfall nicht allein
gelassen werden sondern dass sie von der
Solidargemeinschaft während ihrer
Ausbildung unterstützt werden wir machen
das BAföG damit krisenfest liebe
Kolleginnen
und auch wenn wir natürlich alle hoffen
dass der nothilfe-mechanismus nicht zum
Tragen kommen muss diese Novelle
ermöglicht es uns endlich vor die Krise
zu kommen und nicht mittendrin
eigentlich nachbessern zu müssen deshalb
war es uns als SPD-Fraktion auch so
wichtig dass die Nothilfe zeitnah und
unbürokratisch ausgezahlt werden kann
und jetzt muss man natürlich
ehrlicherweise sagen dass der Nothilfe
mal Mechanismus selbstverständlich kein
Allheilmittel für alles ist er ist dafür
gedacht
temporäre arbeitsmarktbedingte Krisen
für Menschen in Ausbildung abzufeldern
Ausbildungsabbrüche zu vermeiden und
eine planbare zuverlässige und
niedrigschwellige Hilfe zu ermöglichen
für alle weiteren Krisen und
Herausforderungen vor denen zahlreiche
junge Menschen im Moment stehen braucht
es andere Antworten
und wir als Ampelkoalition geben diese
Antworten wir haben mit der im august
erst in Kraft getretenen 27 Bafög
Änderungen nicht nur den Kreis der
Berechtigten deutlicher größer sondern
auch die bedarfsätze angehoben wir haben
den Heizkostenzuschuss geöffnet für
Bafög-Empfänger in wir haben den Rahmen
des jüngsten entlastungspakets
Einmalzahlung für alle Studierende
beschlossen die minijob-grenze wurde
erholt der energiepreispauschale wurde
eingeführt wir werden noch in dieser
Legislaturperiode die größte
strukturreforms seit der Einführung des
Bafögs auf den Weg bringen all das
leisten wir
und wenn es Ihnen das alles zu wenig ist
Liebe Unionsfraktion dann freue ich mich
auf die konstruktive Zusammenarbeit und
die weiteren Ideen ihrerseits zu
Unterstützung der jungen Menschen in
unserem Land uns als Ampelkoalition
haben Sie für diese Ziele ganz sicher
auf ihrer Seite vielen Dank
Lina Seidel war das und der Bundestag
hat heute auch wieder über einen
Stellvertreter der Bundestagspräsidentin
abgestimmt da wurde Michael Kaufmann von
der AFD aufgestellt hat aber die
erforderliche Mehrheit der Stimmen nicht
bekommen jetzt spricht er hier im Plenum
aber zur Debatte sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin geschätzte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Abgeordnete werte Frau
Ministerin mit der 28 Änderungen liegt
uns in kurzer Folge schon wieder ein
Änderung des
Bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetzes vor
es wäre schön wenn das Ministerium
diesen Eifer wenigstens teilweise denn
der Probleme in unseren Schulen und der
Sicherung des forschungsstandorts
Deutschland widmen würde
natürlich natürlich brauchen Studenten
in einer Notlage Unterstützung um zu
verhindern dass sie ihre Lebensträume
begraben und aus finanziellen Gründen
das Studium abbrechen müssen denn damit
wurde gleichzeitig wertvolles Potenzial
vernichtet der vorliegende Gesetzentwurf
ist dafür jedoch nicht das geeignete
Mittel
man hat den Eindruck dass der Text mit
heißer Nadel gestrickt wurde oder meine
Damen und Herren von den
Regierungsfraktionen ist dieser
Gesetzentwurf vielleicht Teil ihrer
Vorbereitung auf erneute
lockdown-maßnahmen das würde dann auch
die ungewöhnliche Eile erklären ich
stelle fest Studenten sind in den
letzten Jahren nicht durch eine
Krankheit sondern durch die umstrittenen
und überzogenen corona-maßnahmen in Not
geraten
und nun und nun legen Sie mit diesem
Entwurf die nächste Gesetzesvorlage vor
in der ein kommender Notstand mit
weitreichenden
Grundrechtseinschränkungen wie
selbstverständlich vorausgesetzt wird
unterstrichen noch durch die angebliche
Eilbedürftigkeit der Gesetzesvorlage
selbst wenn man die Notwendigkeit dieser
Gesetzesänderung anerkennen wollte
was wir nicht tun
krankt der vorliegende Entwurf an
zahlreichen handwerklichen Fehlern diese
Fehler hat nicht zuletzt der
Bundesrechnungshof ausdrücklich gerügt
da ist zunächst die Tatsache dass der
vorgesehene notfallmechanismus zu
schwerfällig und langwierig ist im Falle
einer echten Notlage könnte die
unmittelbar notwendige Hilfe so erst
nach Wochen oder gar Monaten erfolgen
viel zu spät
zweitens der Entwurf sieht vor die
Forderung nach Ablauf von sechs Monaten
unterschiedslos nur noch als Darlehen zu
gewähren damit würden sogar Schülerinnen
und Schüler womöglich noch minderjährig
in die Zwangslage gebracht sich noch vor
Eintritt in das Erwerbsleben erheblich
in erheblichem Umfang Verschulden zu
müssen
drittens ist dieser nach sechs Monaten
vorgesehene Bruch in der Forderung für
Schülerinnen und Schüler wie der
Bundesrechnungshof betont auch
verfassungsrechtlich fragwürdig und
viertens schließlich wurden auch
Personen in den Genuss der Förderung
kommen die darauf gar nicht angewiesen
sind in Verbindung mit dem möglichen
Verzicht auf die Bedürftigkeitsprüfung
wären damit
leistungsmit braucht und
Mitnahmeeffekten Tür und Tor geöffnet
zielgerichtet und schnell ist da nichts
Frau Schröder
[Applaus]
vor allem aber fehlt es dem Entwurf an
klaren Kriterien für die Notlage und die
Bedürftigkeit der Leistungsempfänger wir
fordern Sie daher auf ziehen Sie diesen
Gesetzentwurf zurück
kehren sie zurück zum bewährten Prinzip
dass das BAföG für Auszubildende aus
sozial schwächeren
familienchancengleichheit bieten soll
das setzt zwingend voraus dass die
Leistungsfähigkeit der Eltern und
vorhandenes Vermögen angemessen
berücksichtigt werden im Falle einer
wirklichen Notlage kann der Bundestag
auch im Rahmen der geltenden Regeln
schnell und zielgerichtet reagieren dazu
bedarf es keiner keiner
generalermächtigung der Bundesregierung
die
die analog zum unsäglichen Missbrauch
des Infektionsschutzgesetzes bei vielen
Details im Wagen bleibt und zudem
erschreckend unausgegoren ist danke
Michael Kaufmann hat sich hier gegen
diesen Gesetzentwurf ausgesprochen denn
die Bundesregierung möchte eben mächtigt
werden wenn eine bundesweite Notlager
festgestellt wird den Personenkreis der
bafög-empfängerin und Empfänger zu
erweitern und wenn dort auch ein
negativer Einfluss auf den Arbeitsmarkt
in bestimmten Tätigkeiten
sichtbar ist Nina Stahl jetzt für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Bafög ist seit
Jahrzehnten eine echte Erfolgsgeschichte
die Zugang zu Bildung unabhängig vom
Geldbeutel der Eltern ermöglicht es ist
eins der wichtigsten Instrumente zur
Verbesserung der Chancengerechtigkeit
und deswegen haben wir uns als Ampel in
diesem Bereich auch viel vorgenommen und
wir liefern wir schieben wir schreiben
diese Erfolgsgeschichte fort und mit der
jetzigen Novelle zeigen wir dort wo es
nötig ist passen wir sie an und ergänzen
sie und
und da möchte ich ja zum MC mal mit den
Unwahrheiten aufräumen die sie hier
verbreiten 9 Euro Ticket
strompreisbremse all das hilft natürlich
auch Studierenden fast dreiviertel der
Studierenden haben einen Nebenjob und
haben deswegen auch von der
energiepreispauschale aus dem ersten
Entlastungspaket profitiert und wir
haben natürlich als Ampel auch gezielt
Studierende unterstützt beispielsweise
mit dem Heizkostenzuschuss und im
jetzigen Entlastungspaket mit der
Einmalzahlung von 200 Euro unterstützen
wir weiter Studierende und
fachschüler:innen
aber wir tragen eben auch sorge dafür
dass in künftigen Notlagen Vorsorge
getroffen ist mit dem
nothilfe-mechanismus ziehen wir die
richtigen Lehren aus dem bisherigen
Verlauf der corona-pandemie und schaffen
Prävention für den Notfall
sollte es in Zukunft Einbrüche auf dem
studentischen Arbeitsmarkt geben wird
dieser Rettungsschirm greifen
unterstützt werden schüler:innen und
Studierende der Nebenjob weggebrochen
ist und die bisher keinen Bafög bekommen
haben und das ganz bewusst unabhängig
vom Elternhaus denn eines unserer großen
Ziele dieser großen bafög-strukturreform
ist es das BAföG elternunabhängiger zu
gestalten und das zeigt sich auch in
diesem Reformschritt
wir gießen diese
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen ganz bewusst in
Gesetzesform um jetzt Vorsorge zu
leisten und um Prozesse zu beschleunigen
wenn es darauf ankommt denn in den
Krisensituationen da muss das Geld
schnell fließen und es darf keine Zeit
verschwendet werden mit dem Schnüren
komplizierter Hilfspakete
ein großer ein großer
Erfolg dass alle sich in förderfähigen
Ausbildungen befindenden SchülerInnen
und Studierenden vom nothilfmechanismus
profitieren profitieren können denn
niemand sollte aufgrund externer Schocks
dazu gezwungen sein sein Bildungsweg
abbrechen zu müssen auch das ist
Bildungsgerechtigkeit
und letzter Punkt zum Stichwort
Bildungsgerechtigkeit dieser Schritt der
bafög-reform das ist noch lange nicht
der letzte mit der studienstarthilfe
werden wir gezielt Studierenden auf
Bedarfsgemeinschaften den Staat ins
Studium erleichtern und wir werden
regelmäßige bafög-anpassungen umsetzen
wir werden für den Studien den
Studienfachwechsel erleichtern und die
förderhöchsterdauer anpassen ich freue
mich dass wir heute einen weiteren
wichtigen Schritt gehen um das BAföG im
Sinne der Bildungsgerechtigkeit zu
erweitern und ich verspreche die
nächsten Schritte werden folgen vielen
Dank
die bildungspolitische Sprecherin von
Bündnis 90 den Grünen Bundestag in Nina
Star war das und als nächstes spricht
Nicole Gohlke stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzender der Linken im
Bundestag
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen man muss natürlich der jetzigen
Bundesregierung wirklich erstmal zugute
halten dass sie für den Fall einer
Notlage wie der corona-pandemie im Bafög
eine nothilferegelung fest verankern
möchte weil er ja zumbek das ist eben
schon war die letzte Bundesregierung hat
das nicht gemacht hat sich verweigert
hat das Problem verschleppt und
stattdessen kamen sie eben mit dem
Provisorium der sogenannten
Überbrückungshilfe um die Ecke da traut
man sich jetzt mehr und das ist
natürlich gut so aber was jetzt
ja das stimmt aber was jetzt nämlich als
Gesetzentwurf auf dem Tisch liegt ist
halt eben leider auch nicht Halbes und
nichts Ganzes es wirkt im Ganzen eher
wie so eine Verschlimmbesserung der
Überbrückung Überbrückungshilfe und die
Sachen die dort schon fest geregelt
waren die wirft man dann auch wieder
über Bord und das verstehe ich natürlich
nicht es wirkt leider im Ganzen auch ein
Stück weit wie die Fortsetzung der
Politik des Bildungsministeriums die
Nöte und Lebensrealitäten der von jungen
Menschen nicht sonderlich ernst zu
nehmen und ehrlich gesagt das ist
natürlich nicht sonderlich gut weil das
verspielt weiter Vertrauen in die
Politik und das kann man sich nicht
erlauben und auch nicht bei der jungen
Generation
der Entwurf der Bundesregierung regelt
wenig konkret er lässt eigentlich alles
Wesentliche offen die Bundesregierung
kann dann einiges machen muss es aber
auch nicht und das erfährt man dann eben
auch erst wenn die Katastrophe schon
eingetreten ist und es ist eben nicht
wahr dass so ein Verfahren besonders
viel Planungssicherheit sozusagen
herbeiführt sondern sie fangen dann erst
an zu definieren wer eigentlich was
bekommt sie hätten aber bereits jetzt
zusichern können dass für die Dauer
einer bundesweiten Notlage die
Altersgrenzen die Regelstudienzeit der
Nachweis über das Vollzeitstudium oder
das Leistungsnachweise ausgesetzt werden
warum tun sie das nicht einfach das
würde Verlässlichkeit schaffen das würde
Rechtssicherheit schaffen
und warum öffnen Sie die Nothilfe nicht
für alle Studierenden wie es eben auch
das Deutsche Studentenwerk fordert ich
meine das ist wirklich ein Schlag ins
Gesicht der vielen internationalen
Studierenden die sie jetzt mit dieser
Regelung außen vor und damit auch im
Regen stehen lassen eine notfalllage in
Deutschland macht um diese Menschen
keinen Bogen das ist absurd dass sie das
so regeln und das müssen sie den
Betroffenen wirklich erstmal erklären
und dann stellt sich auch noch die Frage
eben nach dem Ablauf dieses
notfallmechanismus und da schlagen Sie
ein sehr umfangreiches und
zeitfressendes Verfahren vor das
abgespult werden muss bevor die
Betroffenen überhaupt einen einzigen
Cent sehen das liegt daran dass man dann
erst anfängt zu definieren wer
eigentlich was bekommt das geht an den
tatsächlichen Realitäten einer Not und
katastrophenlage ziemlich vorbei und
mein letzter Punkt
warum setzen sie wieder zumindest nach
sechs Monaten auf diese unsoziale Form
des Darlehens und treiben damit junge
Menschen in die Verschuldung das ist
unverantwortlich und es ist tatsächlich
so schön das schlimmsten Fall sogar
Minderjährige Schülerinnen und Schüler
und Azubis nur mit Darlehen unterstützt
werden und in diesem Alter schon in der
Schuldenfalle landen dass es völlig
unverantwortlich Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sie vergeben die Chance eine
notfallmechanismus im Bafög wirklich
passgenau und verbindlich zu gestalten
wie das gehen kann hat die Linke in
ihrem Entschließungsantrag vorgelegt und
insbesondere mit Blick auf aktuelle und
weitere Notlagen fordern wir gestalten
Sie das BAföG endlich existenzsichernd
weiten sie den Kreis substanziell aus
das wäre die beste Grundlage auch in
Notlagen vielen Dank
nächste Rednerin ist Carolin Wagner sie
sitzt im Ausschuss für Bildungsforschung
und Technik Folgen Abschätzung der
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Frau
Bundesministerin Werte Damen und Herren
aus den Debatten zum bafög-novellen der
letzten Monate wissen wir nur noch 11
Prozent der Studierenden beziehen heute
überhaupt Bafög der Reformstau beim
Bafög hat dieses leuchtende
Förderinstrument fast zum erlöscht
Erlöschen gebracht aktuell sind wir
dabei den Funken von damals als Willy
Brandt vor gut 50 Jahren das BAföG
eingeführt hat und das damals 40 Prozent
der Studierenden ein Studium überhaupt
erst ermöglichte wieder zum Glühen zu
bringen und wir arbeiten daran um aus
dem noch vorhandenen Funken wieder ein
Feuer zu entfachen
wir wollen Menschen befähigen und
Begabungen fördern der Geldbeutel der
Eltern darf nicht in Ausschlag geben wer
studieren darf und wer nicht das ist
bildungspolitischer Leitgedanke der
Sozialdemokratie und da setzen wir an
die Ampelkoalition schafft Chancen nicht
nur für die sozialversicherungspflichtig
Beschäftigten für die Familien für die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner sondern eben
auch ganz speziell für die
Auszubildenden die Schülerinnen und
Schüler und die Studierenden neben der
ersten bafög-reform mit der der Funke
wieder entzündet wurde schaffen wir mit
der vorliegenden 28 Novelle einen
notfallmechanismus das heißt wir sorgen
vor und zwar für kommende
Krisensituationen auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
wir haben es heute schon gehört zu
Beginn der Pandemie sind hunderttausende
studentische Jobs von heute auf morgen
einfach weggebrochen zahlreichende
zahlreiche Studierende gerieten
unvorbereitet in finanzielle Notlagen
gar in existenzielle lagen viele wussten
nicht ob sie ihr Studium fortsetzen
können oder nicht und ich weiß dass
meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen in den
Studienberatungen damals diese Sorgen
tagtäglich hörten aber über monatelang
keine über keine Hilfen informieren
konnten werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
diese dramatische Situation darf sich
nicht wiederholen
daher lernen wir aus dieser Erfahrung
und machen das BAföG resilienter
widerstandsfähiger gegen künftige Krisen
und es ist unser Anspruch als SPD und
als Ampelkoalition für die
Zukunftsfähigkeit unseres Landes die
Basis zu stärken und nicht nur einseitig
jenen Chancen zu geben die es sich
finanziell leisten können dafür ist noch
mehr zu tun das wissen wir und das
werden wir auch rasch anpacken mit dem
notfallmechanismus schlagen wir heute
eine Brücke über die Gräben potenzieller
Krisen auf der die Studierenden sicher
weitergehen können wenn unter ihren
Füßen alles wegbricht und wer hat die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union wenn
sie klagen dass der notfallmechanismus
nicht die aktuelle Härte um die
Energiekosten auffängt dann ist es
scheinheilig denn es ist doch ihr CDU
Ministerpräsident in Nordrhein-Westfalen
der die Blockade für das dritte
Entlastungspaket im Bundesrat an droht
und genau in diesem Entlastungspaket
stehen viel mehr stehen viel mehr
Maßnahmen drinnen als die 200 Euro die
sie rausgepickt haben und es ist ihr CSU
Markus Söder der alles blockiert was uns
aus der Energiekrise herausbringt die
Energiewende jedes einzelne Windrad in
Bayern jetzt
nachfolge-euro-ticket und so weiter und
so fort hören Sie endlich auf mit
Augenwischerei die Zeiten verdienen
echte Antworten und die geben wir vielen
herzlichen Dank
als nächste erhält das Wort Katrin
Staffler für die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
anders als die Kollegin Schröder war ich
im Sommer leider nicht wandern ich habe
die Wochen genug schade aber ich habe
die Wochen dafür genutzt um mit
Studenten mit Studentenvertretern ins
Gespräch zu kommen und Einsatz ist mir
dabei ganz enorm im Gedächtnis geblieben
und zwar der Satz Krise ist mehr als nur
Jobverlust ja lassen Sie den Satz mal
ruhig sagen
weil genau dann nämlich der Schwachpunkt
in ihrem notfallmechanismus den wir
heute diskutieren ist wir ergreift
nämlich genau erst dann wenn es
erhebliche nachfrageeinbrüche auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt gibt und das heißt nicht
explizit nicht in der aktuellen
Situation in der die
Lebenshaltungskosten und die
Energiepreise immer weiter steigen das
bedeutet wir sprechen heute über einen
über einen Instrument welches in den
kommenden Monaten wo es ganz hart wird
für unsere Studenten überhaupt keine
Rolle spielen wird schlimm genug
so und jetzt haben Sie heute hier
mehrfach ausgeführt dass wir ganz viele
andere Maßnahmen beschlossen haben um
die Studenten in der um die Studenten in
der Krise zu unterstützen ganzen Haufen
Maßnahmen zum Beispiel die
Heizkostenpauschale die ja aber nur die
Bafög-Empfänger bekommen nicht die
anderen oder die Einmalzahlung von 200
Euro
von der sie aber nicht wissen wie Sie
ausgezahlt werden soll geschweige denn
wann sie endlich ausgezahlt werden
sollen man hört ja der Plan ist der
erste erste eins kann ich Ihnen an der
Stelle jetzt schon mal sagen nächstes
Jahr wird definitiv deutlich zu spät
sein für die vielen Studenten die heute
ja schon nicht wissen wie es am Ende des
Monats sich noch Lebensmittel kaufen
sollen oder oder dergleichen es ist
beschämend was sie hier auf dem Rücken
der studentenaustragung und abliefern
beschämen
[Applaus]
ja ich weiß schon sie haben so viel für
die Studenten getan sie haben mir allein
schon zwei bafög-nobeln in dieser
Legislaturperiode jetzt auf den Weg
gebracht sie haben eine dritte
angekündigt während wir ja nur eine
Novelle innerhalb von vier Jahren
gemacht haben auf dem Weg gebracht haben
aber solche in mein Geheimnis verraten
an der Stelle wir haben nebenher auch
noch ein paar andere Themen gemacht bei
ihnen ist da bislang absolute
Fehlanzeige und davon abgesehen Qualität
ist besser als Quantität und an Qualität
Mangels an der Stelle deutlich jetzt
schauen wir uns zum Beispiel mal diesen
aktuellen
mlp-studentenwohnreport an der ist
gestern veröffentlicht worden für
schrenz hat letzte Woche ganz halt zu
also der MLP studentenwohnreport gestern
veröffentlicht worden bescheinigt an den
dramatischen mieteinstieg der Wohnungen
für Studenten und bis zu 18einhalb
Prozent verteuert wir erinnern uns mal
gemeinsam an die Debatte zum letzten
Bafög zur letzten bafögnovelle da haben
sie den wohnzuschlag für
auswärtswohnende Studenten um 10% erhöht
also zehn Prozent erhöht bei einer 18,5%
verteuerten Wohnungen
mal in die Runde gefragt
haben sie eine Ahnung in wie vielen
deutschen hochschulstätten man mit
diesem wohnzuschlag überhaupt sich noch
eine Durchschnittsmiete leisten kann
haben sie eine Ahnung zwei es sind genau
zwei deutsche Städte
zwei deutsche es ist schlichtweg nicht
ausreichend was sie hier abliefern
so und dass sie das BAföG erhöht haben
ja das war richtig das war dringend
nötig in der Situation in der wir sind
aber die 5,75% Erhöhung der bedarfsätze
sind halt von der Inflation leider auch
schon wieder aufgefressen und genau
deswegen hat auch das Deutsche
Studentenwerk als Reaktion auf den
studentenwohnreport geschrieben dass der
mieteinstieg für Studenten eine exzitat
existenzbedrohende soziale Notlage
bedeutet und das sind wir ja wieder
genau bei dem Begriff liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen Notlage aber halt leider
die falsche Notlage an der Stelle
deswegen jetzt noch mal zu ihrem
notfallmechanismus wir haben im Juli
dazu eine öffentliche Anhörung gehabt in
der haben die Sachverständigen durchaus
lobende Worte für den Mechanismus an
sich gefunden das ist den geben soll
aber eben auch deutliche Kritik geäußert
zum Beispiel am mehrstufigen Verfahren
das ist im Vorfeld braucht
deswegen jetzt die Frage haben sie sich
im Sommer mal hingesetzt und die Kritik
angenommen bei der Kollegin Schröder
wissen wir das die war wandern aber nein
auch der Rest hat es nicht getan haben
sie die angemahnten Änderungen am
Mechanismus umgesetzt nein das haben sie
nicht getan werden die internationalen
Studenten die Auslands-BAföG beziehen
berücksichtigt nein auch die werden
nicht berücksichtigt all diese Dinge
haben sie aus der Anhörung heraus nicht
berücksichtigt
und da kommt bei uns die Frage auf wo
stehen denn die Studenten überhaupt in
ihrer Prioritätenliste ja ganz und wir
verlassen die heutige Sitzung des
Bundestags weil natürlich wir auch Ihnen
die Tagesschau nicht vorenthalten wollen
morgen sind wir dann aber natürlich
wieder hier aus dem Bundestag für Sie da
ab 8 Uhr 45 unter anderem geht es dann
um die Finanzierung der gesetzlichen
Krankenkassen und dort starten wir den
Tag um 8:45 Uhr mit Sepp Müller von der
CDU und Heike Behrens von der SPD im
Interview